The third question we need to ask ourselves
is: what information do readers already know?
This military map of London created by the Soviet
army in the 1980s was designed for use by the that
army in the event of an invasion. The people
making this map would’ve known that their
readers would be familiar with things like
the specialist symbols you can see on this
map. Using those symbols means that the map
makers could squeeze in a lot of information
that might not have been possible if the map
was intended for a more general audience.
Understanding what readers already know also
helps us decide what not to include on a map.
If our intended audience can be expected
to already know an area well we might be
able to leave out things that we would
otherwise have included. Leaving things
out might actually make a map better, if
it means it’s easier for the audience to
focus on the main message of the map. But it
depends on the needs of each map audience.
The next question to ask ourselves is: in what
context are people going to use this map? It’s
particularly important to think about whether a
map will be static – for example if it is going
to be printed out or distributed as a PDF –
or dynamic – for example a map on a website.
Dynamic maps can be zoomed in and
out, and users can often choose to
add or remove layers of information,
whereas if you are making a static map
you need to choose the best scale and which
features to include when you make the map.
If your map is going to be printed out, you also
need to think about whether it will still convey
all the necessary information if someone
photocopies the map in black and white.
The final question to ask yourself when
creating a map is: how could this map lead
the audience to a wrong conclusion? Maps are
powerful tools for communicating information
about the world, so it’s important to
make sure our maps aren’t misleading.
For example this map shows hotspots
of violent crime in London. You can
see that some of the hotspots
are very small and some are more
diffuse. Humans tend to interpret larger areas
of colour on maps as being more important,
which could be misleading if a large diffuse
hotspot actually had fewer violent crimes
than a smaller but more intense hotspot. To
prevent this, when I made this map I numbered
the hotspots so that readers could clearly
see which places had the most violent crime.
So, in summary, every time you make
a map you should first think about:
What will people use the map for?
What information do readers need?
What information to readers already know?
In what context are people going to use this map?
How could this map lead the
audience to a wrong conclusion?